saving money to live out your retirement
dream is important but what happens when
those plans are interrupted because of a
medical problem many times requiring
long-term care well our next guest is
long-term care advisor author susan d
marshall she wrote this book and she has
a way of putting more money in your
pocket and keeping it there
rather than having to spend it on
long-term care welcome to the show
congratulations on your book first of
all
this is this is important information
you and i were just talking about it
during the break why did you decide to
write this book
the beauty of this book mercedes is it
addresses one of the top financial
concerns people have and that is how to
pay for those long-term care expenses
without going broke in the process and
so this book educates and helps to get
those questions answered no i i know
that long-term care can be very
expensive personally in my family we had
to deal with that with my father it's a
lot more expensive than people think
they do they severely underestimate the
cost of long-term care
it could run four to eight thousand a
month and then over a period of eight
years or four years it could add up to
well over two hundred fifty thousand
dollars so
how big of a problem is long-term care
it's bigger than most people realize you
have to consider that we have 8 900 baby
boomers turning 65 every day and
as they age their need for care is
increasing and
the lack of planning for long-term care
is a growing problem and concern in
society
and on top of that alzheimer's
association data shows that
every 65 seconds someone is being
diagnosed with alzheimer's disease so if
you're not looking at your own long-term
care you should definitely be looking at
your family's long-term care
what should our viewers do if they are
concerned about that
encourage you to plan early okay so if
you're in your early 50s start looking
at some of those options if you've been
denied
traditional long-term care there's an
array of alternative solutions and of
course find someone who specializes in
long-term care
someone who not only understands the
problem but the full array of solutions
available
your book is filled with such great
information and we want to help people
get that information whether it is for
you or for a family member thank you to
simplicity acid
based long-term care for sponsoring this
segment and for more information you can
visit to retired.com or call
702-546-8825 and take advantage of their
offer this is really great so susan you
are going to make sure that the next 100
callers receive a free copy of your new
book protecting your future with tax
free long-term care the next 100 callers
get a free copy information you
definitely need thank you so much susan
we're going to send it over to you jc